[Music]
hi I am I'm going to present the
electronic design for Android think
systems are modules my name is Janelle
DeLong I am a hardware engineer for
Android things and I'm really excited to
present you this particular talk
especially because I built hardware for
Google for about 10 years and built for
consumer and enterprise so everything
that you see here are the things that
I've learned over the past 10 years and
please don't repeat the same mistakes
alright let's get started so before I
get into the details of how to build
hardware Android things has system and
module which is the core component of
Android things which has CPU memory
power as well as Wi-Fi and Bluetooth
this is the core component of Android
things which allows you to take all the
complexity out of your hardware and put
the wrapper around it so going into the
detail of this board is about two inches
by two inches and it basically is
something you can buy off the shelves
today so if you were to think of an idea
that you want to build using this as the
core module you don't have to go out and
design it and all the type of complexity
around this has been taken away from it
as part of this particular talk the
thing that we built internally to Google
in a very simplified way is this is this
base board this is the board that goes
with this arm and allows you to add more
functionality to it so imagine use cases
like cameras routers and displays that
would like to use the song as the core
component it's the base board that you
end up designing for your solution it
has in this particular case that I
designed it had a USB ports audio HDMI
buttons LEDs so this is something you
can design this does not require a whole
theme of hardware engineers
to go out and design it for you and I'm
going to walk you through those steps of
how to actually do those things as part
of this to start all right before
jumping into the details of hardware
design again Android things joins this
group of Android platform which are
about 2 billion devices that exists
today as well as it takes advantage of
the android framework so it allows you
to use what you already know for example
even in cases of whether it's cars TVs
watches and very wise as well as cell
phones you're already familiar with
these platforms and now you're using is
to build IOT devices around it from the
ideas perspective and from what this
enables there are a bunch of options to
go out and design in terms of home you
can think about security system speakers
routers doorbells for enterprise
point-of-sale interactive ads vending
machines I'm going to share some
examples of that and for more of a
buildings and enterprise buildings its
cameras HVAC smart meters and for cars
and sleep management you could think
about smart parkings car audios and so
on the opportunities are endless there
will be about 20 billion devices by 2020
and so this really opens up that the
whole opportunity in terms of hardware
how many of you here have actually
designed hardware or been part of the
design
so having having realized a few of them
this is really the we are at this point
where hardware is really not about it's
different or hard it's more about how
you actually go through the process to a
builder so as much as how software is
built hardware is built differently but
if the focus should be really on making
those small steps to get you to the to
the right platform as a more solid
hardware so that there are three things
that have happened in the past I would
say five years that have phenomenal
change the way hardware is built
one there are 3d printers if you think
about a box or a photo frame or anything
that you would like to design you can
actually go print it out today this plus
the IOD platform that we are building
will enable you to build a platform or
product around it secondly there is
crowdsourcing and third is a cost of
manufacturing all these three things
have allowed you to experiment with the
ideas without actually needing a big
team to go out and do it again going
back to this example this along with the
rapper took us one person at Google to
go out and build it these are just two
general examples of what you can do with
it that with the existing solutions for
example a vending machine that doesn't
have a display can start using display
and phone for its checkout the end of
this Android things platform we were
able to you are able to actually
experiment with it as well as the pill
dispenser again allows you to manage the
schedule for the pill the for the pills
as well as notifications and so on again
making something that's been there for a
while and making it smart in terms of so
before before we talk about the process
again this is the board that I was just
showing you the red is the base board
that I design the green is the system of
module that sits on the base board as
you can see this is for was for an XP
device so the song is actually an XP
device but but the base board is is
flexible it allows you to add any
features that you would like to use for
your your for your product alright so
process the first step for hardware
design is planning planning really means
identifying the core components and
features that you want and then
sketching it out a on on paper to figure
out how it all connects
second is prototype prototype is about
actually buying off-the-shelf hardware
and implementing it is an experiment
third is design from a software
standpoint InDesign is making the UI
from a hardware standpoint you're really
getting into the nitty-gritty of using
the schematic tools the layout tools as
well as releasing those for
manufacturing and last is qualified each
of these steps really needs to be
followed and are really critical for the
success of our design and it needs to be
repeated to ensure that you can keep
building more volumes so let's go into
the detail for plan planning from from
the hardware standpoint is really one
identifying the components the features
that you want so you want a USB support
you need a USB connector if you want
audio you need to add audio connector if
you want to use a display this again
needs to go here it's critical to
actually sketch your design up before
you start implementing it this is a
critical step and you need to think
about all the features as well as the
rest of the things which is power and
size so this is in a different dimension
think about how hot this product is
going to get where is it going to be
used is it going to need a very cables
for from your product standpoint beyond
that also think about the cost very
early on so that you don't end up buying
components that are expensive from the
beginning and then finally how is it all
powered is it a battery powered or a see
this also matters in the design so
that's the planning piece next is
prototype I want to emphasize the value
of Florida when you start thinking about
your design and you think that you need
to wait all the way until you actually
design everything in schematic and
layout it's already too late and you
already spend thousands of dollars to
get there so before you do that but try
and see if you can buy components online
put it on the breadboard connect wires
and get your basic functionality in
place again I'm going to repeat get your
basic functionality in place as much as
possible so you know exactly what you
are using
how you're using it how much power does
it draw and even to the extent that how
does it look if you can 3d print
something or use a cardboard it's worth
trying it because by the time you get it
to the production it's going to be too
late
design design is this is something where
most of the software developers are
going to be challenged in terms of how
to actually start implementing this get
the schematics fortunately again in the
last few years there are a lot of open
source options that you can use to start
sketching out your design as an example
he CAD is an open source schematic and
layout tool that you can use today with
no cost and try a simple board there are
a few other options as well from Altium
cadence and ego and each one has its own
pros and cons for example depending on
how many layers the board is or the cost
that you're willing to pay for this tool
each one will be it has its own
trade-offs in my in my particular case
we ended up using Altium mostly because
it's what I knew and as well as what I
was trying to build which was an eight
to ten layer board alright let's take a
little bit deeper into what a schematic
really is so from a hardware standpoint
the schematic is a representative
representation of your design every
component that you can think about
that's going to be on your board it
needs to be on the schematic as you can
see over on to the screen though on the
left side is the capacitors that's
marked as c1 c2 which are the reference
designators the one in the yellow are
generally a6 or connectors the
components that are tied to these
discreet or connector components there
is ground which is represented by the
lines which represents the ground of the
board there is a power which is the
input to the to your circuit and then
all these train
is that you see are all your connections
their physical traces they're going to
be populated onto the board to make
these connections next after you are
finished your schematic the next step is
to start doing the layout layout is in
some sense a 3d representation of what
your design is you start thinking about
where the components go physically on
the design how they are routed not going
into too much detail but this Hardware
has is tied to physics and so how do you
run your single ended and differential
pairs like clocks and signals are
critical in the design and this is where
you can leverage either some help from
online schematic or data sheets or work
with somebody you know but this is this
is where you need to spend some time
thinking about how your board needs to
look where the key components needs to
go this is what the boards layout looked
like and this is just one of the layers
there were eight layers on this board
the traces are the lines that you see
going from the work from top to the
bottom are essentially the physical
traces that were been routed to a
connector the yellow I would say text is
reference designators and if you care
about how you're going to debug this
board you need to ensure that these
things are placed properly similarly
some of the symbols are represent where
the components needs to go once you are
done with the layout the next step is to
see what exactly it looks like and this
is pretty cool in hardware you can
actually start thinking about not only
thinking about what you are trying to
build but also feel and kind of see what
it is and this is where things get
really exciting you need to take the
time to actually look at where your
components are in the in this framework
for example are my buttons in the right
place is LED accessible are the
connectors accessible from
for connecting this is where you can
physically check every single thing to
make sure that they're they're lined up
properly for example one of the issues
that we found when we were designing
with this board is the LED was actually
placed in the back and so it wasn't
visually possible to see the LEDs from
them from the front when they are
blinking especially for error LEDs so
it's important again to think about
these as part of your design after you
are done with this what happens next is
really taken over by the manufacturing
company but what you need to send them
is the Gerber files now if you don't
know what the Gerber files are Gerber
files are representation or a software
text representation of each of these
components the size of the board the
traces the holes that needs to go onto
the board and as well as all the
connections this is a file that you then
sent over to the your manufacturing
company who then ends up building it for
you it's important for them to not only
check this for you but this is also
something that they will help you
confirm that they received all the right
information a critical step in this
process even though it might say the
same simple it might in my case there
wasn't there was an instance where they
received the files but they were
corrupted and they couldn't actually
build the right board so expensive
an important step that you need to pay
attention to in terms of manufacturing
there are two options today which is
really great in terms of the cost and
there are trade-offs for each one so one
is local once your board is ready you
have your Gerber files you could release
it to somebody locally either it's us or
somewhere else which generally cost
higher and here are a few examples of
which you companies you can use or you
can do it offshore there the trade-off
is its cost is cheaper but it also takes
much longer time for you to receive your
boards
it kind of key takeaways for
manufacturing one test every board it is
important that you're building your
board for the first time do not make the
assumption that it's the replica and
it's just going to work you have to test
every single board that comes out of the
line for the first time to visually
inspect before you actually start
powering it on there was an instance
where I had the capacitor reversed and
as soon as I plugged in the power it
actually blew and there was real fire so
this is this is real you've got to pay
attention to your design it does matter
how careful you are before you actually
turn on the power and third if possible
don't wait until the boards are shipped
to you go to the factory if you can see
how as soon as they come out and make
sure that they they work as intended
there have been instances where by the
time they reach after 10 to 15 days you
might find a bug and now it takes
another another set of changes and time
before you can get this error corrected
verses it software you can just do it in
a few seconds all right once you have
your board you received it you test you
check for key components whether they
have been populated properly or not the
next step is to debug you you if you
have some basic EE skills you can use a
multimeter to check your signals and see
if they are wiggling you can use a scope
if you have one but really the key
message here is try and debug as much as
possible I'll give you one example here
that is not obvious to you but under on
the left side or on the right side for
you is the the one that is marked as D
is diode and what we realize as part of
our manufacturing process is that the
diode was actually reversed and this
diode will actually serves a SD card SD
card wasn't detected again visually
really hard to see but this ended up
being a bug in our design where the
the rod was a place reversed and ended
up causing us an audit act for the SD
card thermals I'm briefly going to touch
on thermals but this is an entire turn
to expect aspect of this the hardware
design as well so you would assume that
if the hardware works on your table it's
going to work on your desk it's going to
work everywhere else that's not true as
soon as you start bumping up the
temperature on the hardware you will
start seeing all kinds of issues from
shutdown to heating up some components
and causing fire it's important to think
about the critical components in your
design and make sure you meet the
guidelines and the operating spec of
those components if you can detect in
this particular case I have a heatsink
for the CPU and initially based on our
experiments we realized that heatsink
may not be required after trying a few
experiments on the desk as well as in a
thermal chamber we realized that this
was required to operate the CPU at a
particular temperature range again a
small thing in this design got to pay
attention to it lastly mechanicals after
you are done your hardware design and
finished with the design for it the next
step is what the enclosure looks like
with 3d printing you can sketch you can
print something out and test it out
critical here is to look for all the all
the instances where you're going to
interact with your design if there is a
button make sure it's accessible and
it's in the place where you want it to
be if it is LEDs they should be visually
you should be visually able to see them
from from what is expected out of it
similarly for connectors make sure that
they are not blocked it's always worth
experimenting and printing something out
or use a cardboard too to make sure that
the EE components are in its place
before you go to the next step
in terms of mechanicals there are two
options actually design this design
design it one is called soft tooling and
the other one is hard to link in soft
tooling this is where you use the cost
is higher the turnaround time is again
shorter and it is really designed for
limited use cases so if you expected the
lifetime of a product to be three years
but part that is soft will might last
only a year a hard tool is where you
actually use the sheet metal and use a
hard tooling solution to build your your
your product this is a higher cost there
is a high NRI associated with it a
slower kind of turnaround use mostly for
high-volume products and it's designed
for the full life of the product this is
what you buy when you buy a consumer
electronics this is most of the most of
the tooling is hard told while all the
experimental hardware that you have
internally or in your at your desk for
example might be all the software ok
finally qualify
I think after you have finished all the
all the aspects of this design you got
to qualify your your product from n to n
in terms of software so bring the
hardware up run all the all the software
on top of it and make sure the design is
solid and all the features are meeting
your expectations and set up a pass/fail
criteria for them so that you know
what's going to happen if certain
certain features are turned on and off
this finishes the cycle from plan to
qualify and in some ways you would think
that you are done not yet there take
this process that I just showed and you
need if you are trying to build a
product that's going to be thousands of
units you need to move on to the next
phase which is which is what I'm going
to go through so EVT is the engineering
validation test or the whole process
that I should just showed you needs to
be repeated for
vt generally EVT is about a tens of
units and the goal here to validate your
schematics your layout your design the
core features the components on the
board and ensuring that it all works it
is not really designed to run all the
software that is expected at the end
product the cost for EVT is high so in
some ways you would think that the cost
of the product is going to be high but
that's not necessarily to you true there
are few reasons why the cost for EVT is
high one its low volumes two it is
manufactured in a very controlled way so
there is a high cost associated from an
NRI standpoint and then three the
components that you buy are also going
to be limited and so that's going to
keep your cost high next is DVD DVD is
the design validation process where you
validate the design and also involves
some of the software teams into your
platform this is also where you test out
the software bugs and generally you find
the issues which are 10% of the total
deals so pay attention to those fixing
those and then ensuring that you can
ready to move on to the next stage in
terms of the cost for a DVT platform is
about a few percent lower than EBV the
cost is again driven by the cost of the
board the components that you select as
well as the the process that you are
using
finally pivot is a production validation
test this is generally in thousands of
units and you need to ensure that the
manufacturing line that you have is set
up to handle the volumes that you are
projecting this validates that process
as part of this this step in terms of
the issues that you find are the 1%
imagine now you are building thousands
of units and so you're going to catch
those small bar
that happens in your hardware which you
would have wouldn't have found otherwise
the other focus is really on ensuring
that the process and the line is set up
to go really high cost the cost for PVD
is generally less than half or even one
third of what the cost of EBT is this is
really where the high volume kicks in
along with that the tooling is going to
be high is going to be hard to link so
that means that you're going to start
using much more much better design
solution for your product
finally mass production mass production
is where you are going to start selling
in your units to your end customers this
is going to be thousands of units and
this is where you start also qualifying
your second sources where you start
adding more new components to your
design to reduce cost and the yields are
going to be critical so pay attention to
how your product is performing in the
factory
especially for those small percentage of
failures that you are seeing this steps
is really where the real cost comes in
this is generally like I said they're
less than one-third of the cost of an
EBT or even lower and you can further
push it by using second source
optimizing your processes even kind of
changing some of the design of in terms
of the components that you are selected
and reducing the cost or even removing
them finally you would think you're done
again not yet the there is a bunch of
tests that are required for you to meet
before you can ship out to your
customers and each country has its own
set of compliance tests EMI and EMC test
which is the which is critical to the to
the product and of course your software
qualification so
let's try to wrap this up in terms of
you did the planning you did the
prototype you did the design and then
you did the qualify these four steps
needs to be repeated in each of these
EVT DVT PBT and mass production phases
and each of these steps are designed to
deal with your hardware as I mentioned
earlier if you take these steps and
follow it through most likely your
design will not have the issues that
would cost thousands of dollars that's
the end of this talk I'm gonna they're a
bunch of things around if you haven't
checked out the Android things demo you
can go check it out there's cold labs
and there are also a few other
presentations from Android things team
that you can you can check it out and
they've scavenger hunt if you haven't
tried this yet you should try it you're
gonna get if you can end up getting at
it and I would love to get your feedback
thank
[Applause]
you
[Music]